good morning believe nation today's
message is be willing to be
uncomfortable over to you T Harv Eker
everyone can be rich actually that a lot
of people say well I don't really want
to do this I don't want to do what it
takes to be rich what I want to be
comfortable now that's the problem right
there by the way because comfort and
convenience are the kiss of death to
success so you have to be willing to be
uncomfortable in order to grow and all
that means is that you're going to be
able to do something different that
you've been doing before if you keep
doing what you've always done you're
cute getting what you've always got you
got to switch it up but that's the
problem the problem is most people can't
switch it up they want to and they will
for exactly one day if they're good
maybe today but it's hard to keep it up
why because we're creatures of habit you
will need to change your habits don't
try to change them all at once to do
what happen
you're gonna have to change one main
habit at a time now people just change
one habit I promise you this your life
will change when I was graduating high
school they asked me for a quote that I
could put in a yearbook and what I
responded with was if you want the fruit
you have to go out on the limb and I
believe that's true I believe that if
you stay in your comfort zone
you're never gonna accomplish anything
great I believe that we all live in this
little bubble and if you want the magic
to happen it's by reaching outside you
want to you want to make magic you want
to make an impact you want to make a lot
of money you want to reach a lot of
people then you have to do things that
stretch yourself that make you grow that
make you feel like you're challenging
yourself when I got my agent for my
business he assigned me a media coach
and she started working with me on how
to make my YouTube videos better and she
made me feel super uncomfortable in our
very first sessions she was talking
about how I was too robotic I was too
manly not having enough emotion or
healing and so she made me do exercises
where she put me on the spot and she
pretended to be my wife and I had to
have a conversation with her
and it was just terribly awkward and
uncomfortable but through those
exercises I trusted in the process and I
grew and my videos became better and I
became better as a business person than
as a human being and so every time you
stretched yourself you learned you grow
and you become better
so today I've encouraged you to do
something that makes you feel a little
bit uncomfortable and the question today
is what have you done recently to make
you feel uncomfortable leave in the
comments below I want to learn I want to
find out and I think your story will
help inspire others as well bully thank
you guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso